Gräben Straßensperren Metallzäune
Bild im Protestcamp lützerath
hier im rheinischen Braunkohle Revier
verschanzen sich die klimaaktivisten
bereiten sich auf einen Kampf mit der
Polizei vor
Ziegelsteine liegen auf der Straße
Wurfgeschosse gegen den Ansturm der
Beamten
Energieriese RWE Willy Brauen Kohle
unter dem dorfbagger
doch die Aktivisten wollen es Polizei
und Arbeitern so schwer wie möglich
machen hier würden viele Überraschungen
warten sagt ein Aktivist
die klimakämpfer glauben immer noch dass
sie eine Räumung und die Zerstörung
verhindern können
sie sind bereit
rechnen täglich damit dass die Polizei
anrückt
[Musik]